Les amis, je crois que nous sommes au ski !
*Musique rythmée*
Les amis, c'est l'heure de la première piste, je suis actuellement en train de chausser.
Je vais tester cette board que j'ai eu a noël, je suis très heureux !
Premier essais, on va voir ce que ça va donner ça va être drôle.
*Musique d’exploit*
Je sais qu'on font de vous vous rêviez de me voir tomber, et ben ça a rater mon gars.
*Musique cool*
OK les amis on va maintenant faire le "Boarder Cross". C'est un petit parcours avec pas mal de virages, de petites bosses, c'est assez étroit.
On va tester ça tout de suite. C'est parti !
*La Musique Cool continue*
*Bruit de chute dans la neige*
*Rire*
OK, on peut dire de Jimmy a gagné sur ce coup là.
Jimmy : "Voila !"
Tu m'envoies de la neige quand tu parles.
Ne t’appuies pas sur mon c*l c'est hyper dérangeant.
Bonjour, on est en plein tire-fesses vous et moi. N'est-ce pas romantique ?
Par contre il y a un mec qui est tombé vu qu'on est à l’arrêt.
*Squeezie lâche le tire-fesses*
Attends mais ça remarche !
*Musique de stresse epic*
Christophe !
*Bruitage de ralenti*
*La Musique reprend*
Yolo !! *rire*
OK les amis nous sommes maintenant au "snowboard park". C'est trois bosses qui s'enchainent, on va voir si je m'en sors.
Bon à toute !
*La Musique arrive lentement...*
*La Musique est de plus en plus entrainante*
"It was at this moment, he knew... He fucked up"
*Cri*
Cameraman: "Houuuu"
*rire*
Et le saut de b*tard
*Musique de Mario*
Nous voulons filmer les progrès de Chiera, en snowboard...
Et pour cela on va faire appelle à un drone
*rire* On la voie *rire* Elle fait la meuf, on va voir si elle va gérer.
Va y Chiera, quand tu veux !
Pour le moment on est sur une menteuse mais on croit tous en elle !
Et c'est la chute. *rire* C'est pas grave, c'est le début.
OUI !!
Oui...NON !
Et on va partir sur une descente, attention c'est va aller extrêmement vite !
.
..
...
OUI !!
Oui...Ah c'est la chute. *rire moqueur*
*Musique type RAP*
C'est va Chiera ?
OK
Oui, oui est Non...
Oui oui oui oui oui OUII !! Et c'est la chute !! *rire*
Elle a du mal hein ?
Jimmy : "c'est très beau ce qui se passe"
Squeezie :"Ahh, mais c'est dur mec ?
C'est dommage qu'on puisse pas parler à travers le drone, lui dire :
Chiera t'assures ;) *rire*
Elle en peu plus
Aller c'est la dernière chance, c'est la dernière chance comme "Kyo" (chanteur)
Ah non "Kyo" c'est dernière danse mais c'est pas grave.
*rire*
Ahh non ! C'est la chute !
Les amis un Youtuber ça fais quoi ? Ben ça travaille hein !
C'est quoi tes miniatures, montre nous
"Les sites porn*s" Ahh, le sujet nul ! Oh lala, putain je vais me désabonner
Et tiens qu'est ce tu vas faire
Non non non !
Jimmy : "Tutoriel, pour se désabonner à la chaine de Squeezie. Voila ça dégage"
Squeezie : "Et voila ! Suivez avec précision chaque étape qui constitue ce tutoriel, c'est hyper important"
On va faire du  "Bobsleigh" dans...
Ohhh...
Put*in
Alors je tiens à dire que ça c'est notre nouveau style, c'est juste des t-shirts euhh...
Jimmy : "Thermos"
Est-ce que je vous ai parlé de mes chaussures thermoformées ? *rire*
C'est un délire qu'on a...
Je me suis acheté des chaussures de snowboard grâce à l'argent des abonnés et je les ai thermoformées ça veut dire qu'en gros :
Il les met dans une machine qui les chauffent énormément...
Jimmy : "Tu peux thermoformer ta gueul* ?"
Non mais déjà j'apprends des choses aux gens et je fais pas des vidéos sur des sites p*rnos !
On disait donc, c'est du tissu qui maintien à mort la chaleur, c'est donc un t-shirt thermoformé. *rire*
Non, les chaussures sont thermoformées et le t-shirt il est thermorégulateur voila je suis obligé de lui dire le mot parce ce qu'il le connait pas
(En vrai il est thermorégulant dsl Squeezie)
Ce soir on va faire du "Bobsleigh", c'est une luge qui va extrêmement vite. Il y a une piste olympique ici à La Plagne
*Jimmy coupe la parole à Squeezie*
Tu me laisses...
Voila, ça va être intense, c'est parti on y va ?
*Musique epic*
Les amis ce que vous venez de voir c'est la piste de bobsleigh. Elle fait 1.5 kilomètres de long et elle totalement immense.
Et on s’apprête à partir !
Jimmy : "un maximum de style"
Le style est présent
Oh il est beau regardez on dirait qu'il va faire du karting
On est prêt a pousser et à aller très vite ?
-Jimmy : "Moi j'ai extrêmement peur"  -Squeezie : "Moi aussi !"
Attend il faut ranger la camera faut passer sur la Go-pro aller à bientôt !
Ça va Jimmy ? On est paré !
Monsieur debout : "Allons y !"
On va mourir, c'est sur on va mourir ! Mais on aura une bonne vidéo. *rire*
Oh p*tain
*rire*
Jimmy : "On tape sur un retournement ?"
C'est bien c'est que j'ai mis une Go-Pro mais elle sert à rien
Ohh c'est parti !!!
On est parti Jimmy !!
*rire*
*cri*
Jimmy : "Je suis mort, je suis décédé !"
On est totalement en état de choc !
Jimmy : "C'est d'une violence rare !"
C'est un truc de fou ,et cet enfant de 6ans vient de le faire
On est plus dans le mal que lui.
Du coup si vous vous posez la question si ça va a 200 km/h ? Et ben c'est entièrement faux.
Ça va a 70 km/h mais c’est ressenti 600 fois plus quoi !
Jimmy : "Non ressenti 6000 fois plus" *rire*
Ressenti 8g c'est vraiment scandaleux !
La vitesse à laquelle les gens passe, c'est juste fou. C'était FOU !!
Bon on s'est remis de notre périple et actuellement on va aller faire de la motoneige !
*rire*
On voulait décaler la motoneige pour demain parce qu'on est complétement mort mais on doit tout enchainer.
Mais du coup voila, un max d’adrénaline pour deux gens un peu somnambules.
Mais je pense que la motoneige ça va nous réveiller direct, en plus je tâte un peu la moto sur bitume dans Paris...
...ça na rien à voir !
*rire*
Jimmy : "Moi je fais un peu de skate on va pas se mentir bon ça na rien à voir"
Squeezie : "Non mal la ferme"
*Musique epic*
Placement de produit :)
Jimmy : "Il fait extrêmement froid avec un maximum de vent"
Et derrière qu'est ce qu'on a ?
Une motoneige !
Jimmy : "IQLXT qui est un modèle très ressent, un modèle très stylé vraiment pour les gens qui ont beaucoup d'argent"
Ce qu'on va faire vu que Jimmy est très sympa, il a accepté  de monter à  l’arrière de MA moto pour pouvoir nous filmer comme que je suis en train de le faire.
Jimmy : "Juste pour la première partie parce que après je vais conduire"
*rire*
On va mettre les mains là dessus et j'ai juste hâte qu'ils nous filent des gants et un tour de cou puisque là je suis en train de mourir.
OK les amis c'est parti on y va !
Let's go avec securité !
Il nous a dit les instructions, j’espère que qu'on va pas se gameler ou quoi que ce soit
J'allais déjà faire une connerie, j'avais déjà oublié le Court-circuit Jimmy.
La fraicheur est à 1000% présente et vu qu'on va aller vite, et que ya pas de visières sur ces puta*ns de casques...
Jimmy : "On va se geler les c*uilles !"
*rire*
Eh c'est pas mal, j'aime beaucoup ce qui se passe !
Les amis pour la qualité d'image il fait très très sombre. Il nous a expliqué que, des fois, on va passer sur des pistes de ski,
Où ya des gens la journée, et il va falloir se pencher du côté opposé à la pente.
Et si l'un de nous oublie, ben il va vraiment tomber. *rigolade*. Du coup j'ai trop la pression.
Oh ça va c'est vraiment comme du quad en fait.
C'est extrêmement..*cri* arrête de me filmer comme ça !
*rire sadique*
La technique que tout le monde fait, c'est de marquer un max d’écart avec le mec devant toi, comme ça tu peux faire une petite accélération sympathique.
C'est parti !!
Les amis, ya des gens ont eu un accident, ils ont fait des tonneaux.
Squeezie : "Vous vous êtes pas fait mal ?"
Personnes accidentée : "Ben j'ai un bleu dans la cuisse"
Squeezie : "Ah merd*"
Est-ce que tu veux que je retire un peut la neige qu'il y a ici ?
- Put*in elle a fait un jump la moto neige !
Ah c'est fou
Est-ce que vous pouvez me tenir ça ?
Squeezie : "Exploration "Bulle Pastique" "
Le pare-vent est par terre là bas je crois !
Objectif atteint, mission réussie, je le tiens !
Ok les amis je viens de changer la batterie de la caméra, c'est juste pour vous dire que les femmes que j'ai aidé en mission "Flash Light"...
Elles sont retombées, on s'est retourné un moment et elles étaient plus derrière moi !
Oh Ouii ! Elles sont là on les a retrouvées, faites du BRUIT !!!
*cris de joie*
Et les deux bolosses du groupe sont revenues !! *rire*
ALLEZ, ALLEZ, ALLEZ !!
Alors il s'était passé quoi ?
Moniteur : "Elles étaient perdues"
Perdues ?
Moniteur : "Venez on rentre"
*rire*
Vas’y on arrive !
Et c'est une dure soirée pour ce moniteur de motoneiges !
OK OK c'est la fin de la motoneige mais pas du style nul...
En fait le moment où on s'est arrête, là où on a tous gueulé, c'est juste là on a pas vu que la ligne d'arrivée était à dix mètres.
Donc en remontant sur les motoneiges on a eu une déception colossale.
On est maintenant en zone sure. Alors t'as kiffé Jimmy ?
-Jimmy : "Ben..." -Squeezie : "On sent bat les c*uilles !"
Tu me tiens la main, regardez Jimmy l'enfant c'est parti (traduction approximative) *rire*
Jimmy : "regarde tu le vois ton bâton là? "
Ok, j'ai pris la caméra de Lucas. On part sur de la tyrolienne ce soir, de l’accrobranche de nuit.
On va se faire un max de frayeurs on va pas se mentir. On va essayer de grimper aux arbres sans se vautrer.
On se retrouve tout de suite !
-Squeezie : "Ok les amis..." -Jimmy : "J'ai déjà fais ton intro donc c'est mort !"
Bon ben super, merci Jimmy...
Ok nous sommes arrivés à l'accrobranche, on nous met des petits harnais euh... très sexy.
Et puis ya le parcourt qui est là, il fait nuit c'est illuminé, ya de la lumière à chaque plateforme donc à chaque fois vous verrez des choses avec la Go-Pro.
Je suis extrêmement fatigué, je suis exterminé ! Ça dure 1h30, en revoir Lucas Hauchard !
*rire*
Là on a accroché un Go-Pro au dos de Jimmy et c'est sous cette vue là que vous me verrez pendant tout le parcourt.
Parce que si je la mets là c'est nul vous me verrez pas et on verra juste ce que je fais euh.... Et encore vous verrez pas ce que je vais en fait...
*Squeezie chantonne* "On fait la tyro, la tyrolienne"
On commence d'entré de jeu avec une petite tyrolienne. Êtes vous prêt à voir Jimmy s'envoler  ?
A dieu Jimmy !!
Jimmy : "Et c'est parti !!"
*cri*
*rigolade*
Et c'est trop stylé !
-Jimmy : "Et mais mec on passe dans un arbre" -Squeezie : "Put*in c'est ouf quoi !"
Jimmy : "C'est bon t'es bien placé ?"
*rigolade*
Squeezie : "Jimmy Charlon "La Pannique" *rire* "
*cri*
Whaou, Eh l'arrivée est super violente !
Là on doit monter un échelle c'est parti Jimmy !
-Jimmy : "Non on doit descendre une échelle !" -Squeezie : "La descendre"
Ok j'ai descendu l’échelle assez aisément.
Au revoir !!
*cri*
*rire* + *cri*
*rigolade*
Jimmy : "Cet homme est trop léger, il n'arrive pas au bout" *rire*
Je viens d'arriver j'étais trop léger, MRD j'ai du pousser avec ma force.
Au revoir Jimmy je t'aime
Jimmy : "J’espère qu'on se retrouvera dans l'autre monde !"
A dieu Jimmy
Squeezie : "Va y relève toi petit a petit si tu veux cadrer comme un pro...*surpris* Oh mais c'est incroyable, il cadre avec son dos, oh mais c'est fou mais Jimmy tu es incroyable !
ohh, ohh
Squeezie : "Ça c'est souvent le mec qui fait genre qui  tombe mais qui tombe vraiment !"
*cri de satisfaction*
Ah ça ma tué les couill*s *rire
ah *douleur*
Pour de vrai le harnais il était sur une de mes boulles
3. 2. 1 Yolo !!!
*cri*
*rire*
Je suis en train de mourir !
Jimmy : "Et cet homme descend *rire*
*rire* Oh il m'a assommer le bodriller !
Aller au revoir !!
*Musique d'outro*